the Costa Concordia wreck is kept to one
side of Genoa's Harbor the water is deep
enough there to accommodate what was
once one of the largest cruise ships in
the world specially constructed struts
keep it from capsizing the ship can only
be reached by boat for weeks specialists
have been cleaning out the interior of
the ship the Costa Concordia has to be
made lighter so it can be towed to its
final resting place for scrapping in
Crystal interesting new boggle edge at
the moment it's vital to keep the ship
upright the construction that you see
here secures the ship it's a very
unusual situation because the ship was
involved in such a serious accident
there are also technical difficulties
that we have to solve because the ship
has to be towed later to the dock yard
up to $250 and specialists will be kept
busy with this project for the next two
years it's the first time that anyone
here has worked on something like this
such large cruise liners have never been
scrapped in Europe before safety
officials are finding their work cut out
for them it's their main thing that
aside it's incredibly interesting you
can't get bored here because there's
always something new to learn we're
doing all we can to find the best
solution in the end the difference the
Costa Concordia will be dismantled in
the harbor Basin over the coming months
and some 40,000 tons of Steel will be
recycled the project allows the Italians
to showcase their technical know-how
until now most large ships have been
broken up in Asia amid catastrophic
safety and environmental conditions the
president of Genoa sport authority wants
to change that video the Colombian tally
they offer environmentally friendly
recycling it's more expensive but in the
future international regulations will
require ships to be scrapped in this
manner Genoa is the first port to
recycle a ship in this way
and it'll be ready to make additional
bids because each year hundreds of ships
have to be scrapped stricter worldwide
regulations are set to take effect in
2020 if this mammoth project succeeds
the port is likely to get more contracts
and more jobs and that would give the
port of Genoa a much-needed boost it has
been struggling to keep up with
increased competition in the
shipbuilding industry especially from
Asia